[Music]
what's going on guys
ant-man and the wasp is hitting theaters
and before we became familiar with those
characters from the MCU they weren't
exactly household names today we're
gonna talk about a few other deep cut
characters who may just be the next big
thing in the MCU but probably first you
know her from screen junkies here on the
Nerdist Marvel movie news collider Marky
and McCarty yes that's me and I'm ready
to get really obscure and Marvel with
everybody here thank you and welcome to
the party marki McCarty I've been
wanting to say that this next gentleman
also talks all things superheroes on
Marvel movie news Collider heroes geek
and sundry and he is hosting the new
game the arena yeah I love it so much
he is such a joy his name is coy Chandra
and this man knows his stuff you've seen
them all over screen junkies news movie
fights upcoming appearance on Comedy
Central word on the street has it and
the nerd goat podcast so glad he's here
my man ed Grier I love that so you guys
all had some choices of obscure
characters who may make their way into
the MCU let's start off with Mark eeeh
yeah so okay I kept on trying to think
of individual characters and then I
realized that like the first three that
I thought of we're part of the same like
let's just say faction okay a limited
class Wrestling Federation yeah these
are super humans that were experienced
Adan in some way shape or form and even
mind-controlled and a certain for some
of their cases but they're not
superhuman enough to become superheroes
but they're too super human to be able
to be the athletes that they strive to
be we have set up this universe where
there's meta powered humans there's
superpowers everywhere so why wouldn't
you eventually have the unlimited class
Wrestling Federation you have a she
thing comes from there Sharona Ventura
you have a number of Eternals that
actually like fall in there
Ikaros I believe was one you have the
grapplers that come out of there think
of Glo Witten superhuman powers man that
is a fun deep cut and I think it would
be kind of amazing to have like just
like a special ability wrestling league
yeah ground you can have celebrities in
there that's how we get John Cena yeah
that's some good marketing right there I
like that thank you mark here ah coy you
had uh you had some really fun six give
us one by one as obscure as possible we
got a character her name's Bessie she
produces more milk than the average cow
and one day three hundred years ago
she's bitten by Dracula that's right I'm
talking about hail cow hell Kyle of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe this cow has
been beheaded this cow has come back
from the grave this cow emits vampiric
milk it's an undead cow is one of the
artists of Howard the Duck hell cow is
weirdly involved in Deadpool a lot this
cow and this carrot this cow this
characters from the 70s and still is
used today for no reason it has a back
story it has 300 years of history it has
like people are there's a cult following
of people that support hell cow there's
like a complete organization within the
Marvel Universe that defends undead
animals that held cows the spokesperson
flaw so amazing shield has an entire
department of weird animals that are
cursed
hell cow leads them has however been
killed and made into burgers so hell has
been completely beheaded most up the
body oh then the head came back from the
dead and possessed another cow hell cow
is one of the weirdest characters that
we'll probably never see but if we got
hired the duck as voiced by Seth Green
at the end of guardians plus with
Deadpool's influence I want to see a
Bela Lugosi like improv like voice on
Hell cow I want to hear like a deep
thick accent of Bessie hell cow amazing
I love that I love that that exists and
career to say yes to that yes someone a
degree like my character my character
was somebody who I feel has always
gotten short shrift in the Marvel
Universe both in the comics and
obviously in the movies because we
haven't seen this character yet and the
character's name is
master his ability is to look at
something done once and instantly be
able to reproduce it though he does not
have any actual superhuman powers he's
watched Hawkeye do arrow stuff and now
he's as good as Hawkeye at doing hair o
stuff
he watched Captain America do shield
stuff so he's basically as good as
Captain America at shield stuff and so
on and so forth his ability to look at
you and understand your whole fighting
style give some predictive powers and
battle as well so he's precognitive
genius at fighting of all different
disciplines he could be a very capable
villain for this Captain America and the
next one coming up you know awesome
Edie thanks brother we'll come back
around to Marky Mark he'll what's uh it
was another character that is a deeper
cut okay it's a super-secure and we may
or may not get her goodness knows this
is a black panther character called
princess Zonda she's an immoral Queen
she's a leader of Naru BIA who is
adjacent to what Conda I like her as a
character because her and Black Panther
have this connection and it's like I
would love to see if they incorporated
that somehow I mean her character alone
she decks herself out like a queen like
huge Queen like extra ass I don't see
how they could really incorporate her in
tomorrow but then I also think that they
just could manage it maybe have a really
rich it would it be really rich country
with no morals that kind of hates
Wakanda and but wants to use them to
then collect objects of power and then
you could have princess zonda I mean
black panther made a couple bucks
there's probably means a couple more
black panthers yeah so I don't know may
strange things have happened yeah I'm
down for that okay I didn't count me in
koi so I came up with like 12 we had
narrowed it down one of the ones that
had to make the cut that will probably
never make the cut is my boy hindsight
lad now his only power is basically I
told you so he experiences something and
then he goes well yeah I could have told
you that was gonna happen
he's an annoying like neckbeard that
basically is just like well I could have
told you that wasn't gonna work they
should have done this and he mounts car
mirrors to the sides of his gas so he
can acknowledge things that just happen
because that was so he's the ultimate
hipster he's the guy that goes like well
I liked it before and I could have said
that was good so he's a character that
should never have existed he's amongst
the most annoying characters in comics
I'm basically bringing him up so the
Internet can know that Marvel has made a
character called high yes yeah I have an
app with those same powers thank you sir
Edie I kind of wanted to look at some
characters who were loosely related to
Hank Pym and I found one called
egghead now egghead is a lie estar he is
he's a scientist who has who has a big
egghead
yes but see that egghead there's not all
these super brains in there he's dead
it's just messed up basically he's got
this weird head and he's smart but not
super humanly so but he's evil and one
of the things he got obsessed with was
Hank Pym and Hank Pym technologies Pym
particles to send the other and his
ability with ants so egghead hatched a
plan I see - basically he goes there's
an ant related superhero I'm gonna make
a machine that will make the ants turn
on him that's his introductory story is
them trying to out ant ant man thank you
yeah I'm surprised to find out that
egghead is noyoke
so mark eeeh
please favor us with another obscure
Marvel treat okay so I don't know how
many people know about him monkey
okay I love I love feet holding guns I
just love that okay you're gonna love
hit monkey hey monkey doesn't talk but
he's haunted by a ghost of an assassin
and it is now killing all known
assassins and baddies whenever he can
get across oh it is hit monkey no he
doesn't talk but he doesn't need to you
understand what he says from his
screeches I love that I love from
Deadpool because she this is the
Deadpool yeah that's so crazy
I want hit monkey maybe the Wrestling
Federation make that happen
Sukhoi lay another one on us brother I
gotta talk about a very important
character he is a classic Spiderman
villain he has been known by many names
he is my boy paste-pot pete paste-pot
pete was a genius inventor who could
have made millions off of his paste that
turned to a life of crime and became a
bank robber who sticks people in his
stick sticky white goo was also known as
the Trapster for a time this character
has lasted 60 years
he thinks he's Doctor Doom like he talks
like he's this brilliant mad scientist
Wow just shoots glue at people coy that
is so dumb and food I want to hear one
more edgy ova another fave that you
oughta he's an OG super villain and I
think you can see that the world has
passed him by a little bit and his name
is the porcupine ah now the porcupine I
guess you know those great stories of da
Vinci looking at birds or or you know
the Wright brothers looking at
dragonflies or whatever well I guess he
was looking at a porcupine and decided
that is the illest animal I've ever seen
in my life and he dedicated himself to
making a porcupine suit so the porcupine
decided to try to market his his
invention to the government he worked as
a government person and the bottom line
is the government was like I want to
give you know my goofy ass stuff he was
like what and so he went off on his own
and became a villain using this
technology that's so great Edie
many sharp points on porcupine so we
heard some of your faves are there any
more deep cuts let's have some honorable
mentions a little bit of a speed round
throw out some character easily Captain
America character superior also known as
a Deidre Wentworth she was a scientist
that gave herself superpowers there's
this whole time play aspect of where she
goes back in time she's part of the
famines and she's trying to make the
world the woman's world population
sterile so that only their offspring go
into the future I know I know thank you
for that and you know there are any
other honorable mentions so I got a
couple that I got to give some love to
doctor bong is basically an even lamer
Mysterio dr. bong is a man let me get
this straight this has nothing to do
with weed nothing against all odds' dr.
Hong lost his hands so he's got little
like club' things to bong his head and
he wears a giant like bell on his head I
want to invent dr. bong 3.0 where he's
just like this kid he goes to college
campuses and he makes you think about
all them and a sidekick is a yo vape boy
these lad
thank you for bringing it back he looks
like a mix between Daredevil and
Wolverine and he's just this stocky guy
that does not much I want to talk about
3d man basically as soon as 3d glasses
technology came up somehow he gets
trapped in the 3d glasses so in order to
enact his power someone must put on said
3d glasses and he jumps out and for
three hours he's pretty strong pretty
fast and kind of a hero type I guess
yeah for three hours and then if the
case is no more three glasses in the 90s
in the 90s or late 90s I think they
introduced a character called triathlon
triathlon who runs fast yeah people
hated him and he sucked and he decided
to rebrand himself as 3d man so he was
so 3d Man is not only a stupid garbage
character but now he's a legacy legacy
garbage character you've schooled us all
today in the obscure the weird the deep
cuts I'm gonna put each of you on a spot
tell me who do you think realistically
it could actually make their way into
the MCU I mean I added start with you I
personally really do think taskmaster
could do it done right strip away some
of the stupid stuff he's good enough to
take on whole team because he has so
many skills bad thank you sir coy pick
one so I all of mine were more about
bringing awareness none of mine will
ever see the boy thank you Mark yeah I'm
definitely gonna go with the wrestling
federation I mean I'm completely
unlimited class these all need to happen
I don't know if any of them will but uh
I love them all what are some more
obscure characters that you were like
hey what about this one what about that
one let us know in the comments section
below who would you love to see enter
the MCU tell us that as well Edgar
Iroquois and row marquee McCarty thank
you so much for coming by always great
to have the three of you in studio and I
want to thank you for watching screen
junkies I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter
[Music]